Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in the
audience. We now use discord to hear from people.
You can go to David Pakman dot com
slash discord to find the discord.
And we're going to speak to people. Let's
go first to Michael in Philly. Michael,
you are on the air. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Thanks. Thanks for picking me, David.
Speaker 5: I was wondering a lot of people think
this. It's a really, really bad idea at this
point in time, considering how widespread the
al-Muqrin variant is. It's my guess that's what
my question concerns are. Do you think that here
in the United States, because of how mutations
can sometimes be worse than people expect on
the time being an example? Do you think that
mandates of any kind? Oh, our bad idea.
Speaker 1: Are you when you say that
when you say mandates of any kind, are you
saying vaccine mandates or other mandates?
Speaker 5: I mean, are you mad at me?
I mean, maybe it's a fairly common
mandate vaccine mandates, gathering
mandates and mandates of any kind.
Speaker 1: Right now, we're at any point.
Right now, I'm I think that for the next month,
there still should be some restrictions, but
I agree with people like Vincent Racaniello
that we are getting close to close to the point
at which it's going to start making sense to ease
up on a lot of these different things. I think
businesses requiring people to be vaccinated,
it's up to the business. It's completely legal
and I think it's fine. But I do think that as
we move in the direction of end the misery and
it's completely impossible to avoid exposure at
this point. Exposure, remember, not infection.
We're certainly we appear to be moving in the
direction where it's going to start to make
sense, to ease up off a lot of that stuff.
Now that could change, that could change.
All right. I appreciate the call. Thank you
a lot going on there, background noise and
other other noises and sort of different
things. So we're going to move on for the
time being and I do appreciate the call.